Arkadaşlar merhaba ben üştü Hoca tüm 9
sınıf öğrencilerime selam olsun çılgın
bir video serisi yine başlıyor ikinci
temaya geçmiş bulunuyoruz ikinci temaya
geçtik hikayeyi konuşacağız 9 sınıf
güncel müfredatta hikaye ile ilgili ne
bilmeniz gerekiyorsa eksiksiz Bu videoda
E o zaman haydi başlasın Evet notlarımız
geldi Arkadaşlar şimdi çılgın notlarla
karşınızdayız hikaye ile ilgili ne
bilmeniz gerekiyorsa Derli toplu en
güzel Halile İşte karşınızda bunları
biliyoruz yatıp uyuyoruz başka bir şey
yapmıyoruz ekstra bir çalışmaya
ihtiyacınız yok okulda zaten yeteri
kadar etkinlikler grup kurmalar grup
oluşturmaları arası yarışmalar falan
sürekli etkinlik etkinlik etkinlik
etkinlik işte bilgi boyutunu da buradan
H etmiş olacağız inşallah hikaye Diğer
adıyla Öykü kardeşim Öykü Öykü cepte
kalsın Şimdi öyle bir altını çizdim ki
Allah aşkına bak bu nasıl bir altını
çizme ya altını çizemedim ya şimdi oldu
Evet süper bir hikaye dediğimiz zaman ü
şey hatırlayacağız seveceğiz düce onu da
çözeceğiz Hocam düce ne demekse artık
Serim her şeyi anlattığın adeta gözler
önüne serdiğin bölüm giriş bölümü canım
düğüm düğüm attığın adeta birbirine yani
gelişme bölümü sonrasındaysa çözüm Yani
sonuç bölümü o düğümü çözeceğiz ü tane
bölümü var bir hikayenin olması gereken
bu cepte bir kalsın konuşacağız Yapı
unsurlarına baktığımız zaman kişiyi
olayı yeri zamanı temayı çatışmayı
göreceğiz ki çatışma Bunlar arasındaki
en favori başlıktır son günlerin güncel
müfredatın olmazsa olmazıdır 10 sınıfta
da çatışmayı soruyorlar 11 sınıfta da
çatışmayı soruyorlar 12'de de çatışmayı
Sor her yerde bir çatışma sorusu geliyor
artık o yüzden çatışmayı yani mücadeleyi
zıtlığı olay örgüsüne yön veren şeyi çok
iyi bilmelisiniz geleceğiz anlatım
biçimleri öyküde iki anlatım biçimi olur
Başka bir şey olamaz ya
betimlenir ya da ö
öykülerin değil mi öyküle isin Evet ya
da öykülem öyküleyici anlatım biçimi iki
tane anlatım biçimimiz var cepte kalsın
hikayede kullanılacak kullanılabilecek
dikkat anlatıcı noktasında 1ci ya da 3ün
kişi anlatımı olabilir sadece birinci
kişi anlatım Yaptım Ettim Ben derken biz
derken Benli bizli anlatım yaptık ettik
e 3üncü kişi de yaptı etti gördüm bu
kadar anlatıcı bakış açılarına
baktığımız zaman kişilerin ruhsal
dünyasında bilen ilahi bakış açısı e
olayı yaşayan kişi olarak Kahraman bakış
açısı ve gördüklerini anlatan sadece
diye adlandırabileceğimiz kameraman yani
gözlemci bakış açısı cepte kalsın
anlatım tekniği noktasındayız diyalog
kişi tanıtımı olay tanıtımı geriye dönüş
hepsi Adı üzerinde Zaten özetleme iç
konuşma gibi gibi gibi bazı teknikler
var cebinizde Kalsın 9 sınıf güncel
müfredat MEB takipte ne bilmeniz
gerekiyorsa işte tahtada Hocam işte
ekranda Hadi bunları işlemeye başlayalım
Yalnız çok önemli bir şartım var Bu
olmazsa anlatamayız arkanıza yaslanın
Allah aşkına şartım bu arkanıza yaslanın
ya Acelemiz yok şöyle arkanıza bir
yaslanın rahat rahat ya bu adam ne
hazırlamış Acaba ona bir bakalım tamam
Dışarıda Kar Yağıyor Kartop oynasın var
Tamam çıkasın var Benim de öyle şimdi
Allah var Yalan yok Ankara'dayım
Arkadaşlar ben biliyorsunuz şu an yani
Göz gözü görmüyor inanılmaz Lapa Lapa
bir kar yağışı var inanılmaz bir kar
yağışı var benim de bir çıkasım kart
topu yapıp atasım var da o kart topundan
önce bu videoyu atmam lazım E o zaman
hadi başlayalım Hakkını Verelim abone
olmayı unutma yorum yazmayı unutma
gelsin videomuz Evet şimdi b orası lazım
Bak ben sana söyleyeyim Öncelikle sözlü
dönemde destanlar vardı geçiş dönemine
gittiğimiz zaman Dede Korkut Hikayeleri
falan Divanda Mesnevi halk hikayesinde
halk hikayeleri ve tanzimat döneminde
artık hikaye öykü Yani bugün
konuştuğumuz şu an konuştuğumuz öykünün
geldiği nokta bu işte ama en önemlisi
Tanzimat Döneminde tam anlamıyla
karşımıza çıktı yaşanmış ya da
yaşanabilir olaylar anlatılacak durumlar
anlatılacak öyküde değil mi şimdi kişi
sayısı oldukça sınırlı oldukça Evet
oldukça sınırlı kişi sayısı az abi az
hikaye kısadır Roman uzundur bitti
Aralarındaki fark at gitsin çöpe bu
kadar hikaye kısa daha kısa kişi sayısı
az olaylarda ayrıntıya çok fazla
girilmez kahramanların genellikle bir
yönü üzerinde durulur zaman ve mekanda
dikkat ayrıntı yok hikaye ile ilgili en
önemli bilgi Bu arkadaşlar ayrıntı yok
ayrıntıya çok fazla girmiyorsun girersen
Roman olur anlattığın şey de detaya
girersen Roman yazmış olursun değil mi
düşündürmek çok duygulandırmak ve
heyecanlandırmak esas bakın burası çok
önemli kahramanlar bir yönüyle şu kısım
önemli şurası önemli kahramanlar bir
yönüyle anlatılıyor daha çok zaman mekan
vesaire ayrıntıya asla girmiyorlar kişi
sayısı az bölümlere baktığımız zaman
Serim Yani olay anlatımına başlanan yer
kişiler tanıtılıyor yer ve zaman
belirtiliyor soğuk bir Kasım sabahıydı
diyor Tamam Ahmet diyor yola çıkmıştı
Tamam karakterleri aldım olayları aldım
Artık başla diyor başla serdim her şeyi
ben diyor Ne yapacağız düğüm atacağız
düğüm okurda merak oluşturmaya
başlayacağız düğüm bölümünde çözümde ise
artık okurun merakı gidecek şekilde sona
erdireceğiz olayı not olay hikayeleri bu
plana göre yazılırken durum
hikayelerinde bu plana bağlı kalınmaz
hocam olay hikayesi durum hikayesi ne
Allah aşkına şimdi onu göreceğiz
birazdan birazdan Acelemiz yok Yavaş
yavaş her şeyi bilelim bu müfredatta ne
bilmemiz gerekiyorsa işte bilgi işte
Detay Hocam bunu bileceğiz devam e
Geldik hikayenin tarihi gelişimine
Öncelikle biliyorsunuz dünya
edebiyatında 14 yüzyılda batıda ortaya
çıkacak ama çöp bilgi bunu geç Bize şu
lazım ilk örneğini bocacho verecek
decamer öyküleriyle çok önemli bir bilgi
altın değerinde bir bilgi cepte kalsın
Hocam bunu bilmeden sınava mava girmek
yok biliyorsunuz masallar Dede Korkut
Hikayeleri halk hikayeleri Aman
mesneviler falan derken günümüze hikaye
olarak geliyor böyle bir Gelişimi var ve
tanzimatla edebiyatımıza girdiğini
unutmayın Tanzimat Dönemi bilgisi bu çok
önemli Ahmet Mithat Efendi'nin letaifi
rivayet adlı eseri ise il ilk yerli
hikaye olma özelliği taşıyor nasıl
Onlarda bacon'un decameron var bizde de
Ahmet Mithat var abi Letaif rivayat var
e Geldik başka bir bilgi hocam teknik
açıdan güçlü Batılı anlamda ilk hikayesi
Sami Paşazade Sezai'nin Küçük Şeyler
adlı eseridir biliyorsunuz ilk yerli
letaifi rivayat ilk batılı anlamda Küçük
Şeyler Hikaye türünün başarılı
örneklerini ise Servet fundan milli
edebiyatta ve Cumhuriyet döneminde
göreceğiz yetmez güncel müfredatın en
güncel bilgisi gelsin Gelsin hocam Evet
geldik hikaye türlerine en önemli kısım
burası Bak ben sana söyleyeyim En lazım
kısımlardan bir tanesi Burası bunu bir
kere cebine koyman lazım Hocam şimdi
olay hikayesi dendiği zaman benim aklıma
ne gelecek serim düğüm çözüm gelecek bir
olay ya bir klasik hikaye yani bu kadar
olay anlatımına dayalı olduğunu
biliyoruz Serin Düğüm çözümü olduğunu
biliyoruz anlatılanların daha çok
kronolojik akışa sıraya uyduğunu
biliyoruz mantıksal bir sonuç Eyvallah
kahraman ve çevre tasviri Eyvallah
okurda merak Evet merak unsuru heyecan
kesinlikle var arkadaşlar Ömer ef ettin
Refik alit kar Reşat Nur Güntekin Yakup
Kadiri kesinlikle bilmeniz gereken en
önemli isimler ya olay hikayesini
biliyorsunuz mopasan tarzı hikaye olarak
da biliyoruz Maupassant dünya
edebiyatında
Maupassant aman dikkat mopasan diye
söylüyoruz lütfen cepte kalsın kurucusu
başlatıcısı bu ama anlatımı Türk
edebiyatı odaklı olduğu için Buna
ihtiyacımız yok mopasan cepte kalsın Biz
de Ömer Seyfettin var kardeşim Refik
Halit var Reşat Nuri var Yakup Kadri var
cepte lütfen kalsın durum hikayesine
baktığınız zaman Anton chov chov tarzı
Rus yazar chov tarzı da deniyoruz
diyoruz olaya değil de günlük hayattan
bir duruma kesite dayandığını biliyoruz
durum hikayesine kesit hikayesi de denir
kesit öyküsü de denir ya bir sonuca
bağlamak yok Bak en tipik bilgisi bu Bak
sonunda bitmemişlik hisi verir en önemli
madde bu biliyor musun gerisi çöp gerisi
çöp en önemli madde bu E yani bir anda
bitiyor hikaye adam camın kenarındaydık
çiçeklerini sul ve bir gün kalktığında E
yani Ne oldu abi anlat ya devam et adam
bir çıksın gitsin koşsun yok Durum
hikayesinde böyle bir kopukluk böyle bir
Bilmem kendini bilmezlik bir ben ne
olumlar falan durum hikayesinin
görüntüsü bu adam camın önünde bakıyor
mesela bakıyor çiçeği suluyor tekrar
alıyor geçen biri var selam veriyor
falan fistan E sonra bitiyor hikaye yani
böyle bir şey bu Allah aşkına mantık
ögesi ikinci planda Tabii ki kronolojik
akışa genellikle uyulmaz arkadaşlar
genellikle uyulmaz serim düğüm çözüm
şeklindeki plana da bağlı kalınmaz Ya
ben olay hikayesini çok iyi bileceğim
tam tersi olarak durum hikayesini kabul
edeceğim bütün mesele bu onlarda ço
varsa bizde memu Şevket Esen dal var
Sait Faik var Oktay Akbal var vüsat
Orhan Bener var Nasıl Sabahattin Ali
varsa olay hikayesinde Burada da Selim
İleri var Bilge Karasu var çok önemli
isimler var Bunlar da lütfen cebinizde
kalsın arkadaşlar Evet geldik anlatım
biçimlerine anlatım biçimlerini adımız
gibi bilmeliyiz Arkadaşlar bunlar kilit
noktalar şimdi öyküleyici anlatım
Öyküleme betimleyici anlatım betimleme
olarak geçiyor öyküleyici anlatımda olay
var burada resim çizme var aslında yani
bir anlamda öyküleyici anlatımda video
izliyorsunuz betimleyici anlatıma bir
fotoğrafa bakıyorsunuz Lütfen bunu
unutmayın fotoğrafa bakma var
betimleyici de öyküleyici de olay var
Yah betimlemede öznel olana izlenimsel
betimleme nesnel olana açıklayıcı
betimleme deniyor ama Bu bilgiye
ihtiyacınız yok arkadaşlar çok da aman
aman bunu bilmenize gerek yok burada
bilmeniz gereken aslında betimleme genel
başlığı Yani siz sıfatlarla dolu
detayların ayrıntıların olduğu bir şey
yakalarsanız mesela sağ kolda bir tek
büyük tahini boyalı tahta Konak vardı
diyor mesela alı büyük falan fistan bir
tarafa bakıyorsun ev halkı tekrar
birbirine düşmüştü kimi gün Ferhunde
sinini pay kırıyor kimi gün Ayşe
ağlıyordu falan derken öyküleyici de
olay var betimleyici de duranlı var
bitti cepte kalsın e Geldik anlatıcı
türlerine şimdi lütfen dikkat Tamam
anlatan kişidir kurmacadır bak geç
bunlar bunlar önemli değil bizi
ilgilendiren birinci kişi ağzından
anlatım ve 3ün kişi ağzından anlatım
nedir ne değildir Tamamdır o önemli
şimdi anlatıcı olayın içindeyse ben biz
gibi özneler kullanıyorsa yaptım ettim
bakın başladım diyor değil mi attım
parçaladım böyle bir şey diyorsa ya da
sınıfça şuraya gittik yaptık ettik
diyorsa birinci kişi ağzındır ben ya da
biz varsa 3ün kişi anlatım saysa o ve
onlar var bakın ne diyor hemen aşağıdan
bulalım başladı parçaladı attı o diyorsa
Buna da 3ün kişi ağzından anlatım
diyoruz Bu da cepte kalsın Ya arkadaşlar
şu bakış açıları da cepte kalsın ya Eğer
böyle karakterlerin Aklından geçenleri
dahi biliyorsa bu adam ona ilahi hakim
tanrısal bakış açısı diyoruz yani kitap
okumak istedi bak canı kitap okumak
istedi raftan bir kitap okumaya başladı
gizemli bir dünyanın kapılarını
araladığın düşündü düşündü canının Bunu
istemesi zihninden geçenleri biliyorsa
hakim bakış açısı Eğer olayın içindeyse
bakın ne diyor başladım atmıştım adım
atmıştım ben diyorsa olayı yaşıyorsa
Kahraman bakış açısı Eğer yaptı etti
başladı belirdi gördüklerini anlatıyorsa
gözlemci bakış açısı biter şimdi
arkadaşlar biliyorsunuz girişte Hani
Yapı unsurlarından bahsetmiştik ya kişi
olay mekan tema konu çatışma anlatıcı
zaman falan bunlarda bir şey yok yani
olayın yaşandığı yere mekan denir yaı
yaşayan kişiye kişi denir yaşandığı
zaman zamandır falan saçma zaman buna
gerek yok ki ya bunla niye vaktinizi
çalalım Allah aşkına işte olaylarda
öyküde geçen kişiler kişi kadrosunu Bu
ne abi Allah aşkına bu değil arkadaşlar
size lazım olan şey burada çatışmadır
kişi kişidir olay olaydır mekan mekandır
burada bir sıkıntı yok ki sıkıntımız
çatışma nedir ne değildir Hadi gelin
onun İşini bitirelim hocam o bitsin Evet
çatışma Geldi Hoş Geldi Hoş Geldi hocam
başımızın üstünde yeri var şimdi
çatışmadan kastımız ne çatışma demek
zıtlık demek zıtlık zıtlık zıtlık Yani
bir yerde doğu batı çatışması bir ağ
köylü varsa mesela hikayede Ne bileyim
romanda iyi kötü varsa bu bir çatışma
yaşatır o insana değil mi Bir çatışmanın
başlangıcıdır onun fitilini ateşler
mesela Fatih Harbiye'de doğu batı
çatışmasının işlenmesi gibi ya da
Sinekli bakkalda vesaire farklı
düşüncelere özelliklere sahip olmaktan
ve hayat tarzından dolayı yaşanan anla
durumları Bakın arkadaşlar bir zıtlık
arayacağız bir mücadele arayacağız
Mesela ben size şöyle söyleyeyim
kendiniz sizin üzerinizden gidelim
mesela Siz ne istiyorsunuz yazılım
mühendisi olmak istiyorsunuz mesela Ama
anne ve babanız Tıp okusun diyor ne
olursa olsun Tıp okusun Niye Çünkü
amcaya tıp okuyor Benim kızım diyecek
Çünkü teyzeye benim oğlum tıp okuyor
diyecek de o yüzden başka ne olacak
Allah aşkına O istediği için başkalarına
böyle hava olsun tıp okuyor Benim kızım
benim oğlum maalesef maalesef maalesef
böyle bir algı var mesela bir kısımda
Tabii herkeste değil herkeste değil bir
kısımda var ama sen böyle içten içe ya
Annem öyle istiyor ama ya Bir yazılım
okusam var ya öyle olacak ki hocam ya
Mükemmel olacak ya da Hocam ben Vallahi
bir makine mühendisliği okusam neler
neler yaparım da annem babam yani tıp
istiyor Yapacak bir şey yok diyorsun ya
işte sen bir çatışma yaşıyorsun sen
çatışmanın merkezindeki kişisin Sen
çatışmanın ta kendisisin Sen
çatışmasının
ya Yani illa çatışmanın böyle fiziki bir
şey ya da görünür bir şey olması a bur
da köylü burada Tamam işte iyi insan bu
kötü insan bu Tamam olması gerekmez
zihinsel anlamda kişinin içinde yaşadığı
çatışmalar da olabilir yani eserde bir
mücadele bir zıtlık istiyorsanız
buluyorsanız Daha doğrusu görüyorsanız
onu lütfen çatışma kabul edin ve çatışma
öykünün temelidir mutlaka bir yerlerde
bir çatışma Olur tabii ki olay
öykülerinde durumda ne olacak durumda
adam camın önünde pencerede şey suluyor
ya çiçek suluyor Ne yapacak o adam o
adamın ne çatışması olacak Allah aşkına
Acaba hangi çiçeği sulasam demez bu adam
ya sular çiçeği geçer gider bize olay
hikayesi lazım olay hikayesinde çatışma
merkezdedir zıtlık tır mücadeledir
Lütfen bunlar cebinizde kalsın hocam E o
zaman güncel müfredatta ne bilmeniz
gerekiyorsa konuştuk içiniz çok rahat
olsun hikaye ile ilgili konuştuklarımız
size çok ama çok lazım olacak Çok
işinize yarayacak Ben sık sık yanınızda
olmaya çalışacağım kanala abone olmayı
unutmayın yorum yapmayı unutmayın
yorumlarda istediğiniz videoları
istediğiniz konuları Ne yaptığınızı
Yazın olur mu Hangi okuldasın Ne
yapıyorsunuz İşte hangi konular bitti
nasıl işleniyor hepsini istiyoruz Haydi
görüşürüz Kolay gelsin